foreign
ER of the end of the Robert Frost poem
two roads diverged in wood and I I took
the One Less Traveled by and that has
made all the difference
when I read to you that section of from
the Pullman book which began with that
um
a bit from Robert Frost poem
one of your reactions was
it's like
it's like the question of how do you
teach somebody to think about a tropical
forest uh
I preferred what I heard you say the
first time which is it's like being in a
tropical forest you know forget teaching
you know forget pretending that we
already have the stuff and but it's like
it's like walking into tropical forest
it's like walking in the sense and
discovering not the actual path that you
may or may not be on and may lose and
and all this but
starting to say oh oh there's there's
that and there's that and there's and I
don't
how do I make sense of this and as you
know as we say actually in the
um forward to the book
um
our very first not our very first trip
into the tropics but our second trip as
biologists when we were working there as
graduate students with John Vander one
of our professors
um he walked into the fort into the
rainforest in Costa Rica and said you
know look at all the questions
and my response was I just see a lot of
green like that's any questions here at
all and they started showing up they did
they did
um but it took a while because it's so
much because the wood in that case is an
actual wood it's an actual rainforest
and it's so complex and it changes so
fast from like one foot to the next the
next foot and
um I'm talking about like measures of
distance rather than actual feed
um and I mean you can if you're trying
to teach it you can have a path in mind
of what it is that you're trying to
teach
um but it's all it's all still the the
wood and it's so complex right well the
reason the reason I would make the point
in the way you like uh less okay is
a just be aware this conversation takes
place in the context that we do not know
very much about how tropical forests
work they are so complex that it is a
very difficult puzzle to sort them out
and so nobody here is pretending that we
understand them well enough and that we
are teaching the students to understand
them well also because that's not the
state of play but
the question of how you start you walk
into a forest and you could start by
thinking about it in terms of canopy
layers and what creatures live in each
of these canopy layers you could start
thinking about it trophically the energy
is captured by the plants in the form of
sunlight turned into sugars and starches
and and cellulose by photosynthesis
um the heterotrophs eat the plants right
yeah there are a lot of ways you could
do it by the biomass of different
uh kinds of organisms you could do it by
phylogenetic systematics
none of them are correct
all of them are complete none of them
are the correct way
ah none of them are the correct way if
done properly they are all correct and
hopefully self-correcting and as we say
I think a couple times in our book
all true narratives must reconcile all
true scientific stories must reconcile
that's where we come full circle with
with Robert Frost here right yeah so the
point is actually you have to get
comfortable if you're dealing with
something like a tropical forest you
have to get comfortable with the fact
that you are picking a literal path
through it whether that path is
analytical or physical that path is not
it is a kind of the map is not the
territory the path is not the sum total
of the forest yeah but
anyone will do
actually
yes any any path
uh will reveal something that is
consistent with any other path if the
path is true within that wood right and
um the little bit of research that I
want to share here is actually
ah I'm reminded with regard to the wood
and the path of being in Madagascar the
first time where we went
um where we went after we graduated from
college
and I was we were in Ankara in the far
north
and it's it's a strange and magical and
strange place and uh there's very little
surface water
mostly you have to go deep into these
caves and you can walk underground in
these these Caverns into these like
pockets of forest where the karst on the
Limestone cars has collapse and you've
got these pockets of forests that are
connected to the outside world if you're
a bird you can fly in but if you're like
a lemur you're there for life or you
have to go through these caves and they
don't presumably but anyway I was
sitting there and in one of the few
places where service water exists in
karna with a little stream watch and
crowned lemurs which are beautiful
um
you know lemurs being these relatively
basal primates that are only in
Madagascar and I was watching them eat
the fruits of tamarind
and I thought I don't I don't think
Tamarind is from here and I had no way
to know that then but I you know once we
came back and this was between college
and uh we were going to be starting grad
school that fall in Michigan and I and I
looked into it and went yeah Tamarind
was into it's in Indian fruit that was
introduced by humans to Madagascar who
liked who were cultivating it and so my
hypo because it's super delicious it is
delicious it's weird it's it's also like
on car and it's a weird fruit it is um
and you know you have to have a taste
for it um but it's it's delicious uh and
it's it's very much kind of a mammal
fruit where you have like you it's it's
got this this thick husk and you have to
work on it with your thumbs so it's it's
probably you know very good for primates
in general and then you end up with
these big seeds that you have to kind of
suck on and chew on for a while to get
all the all the good fruit pulp off
um
but I thought ha I wonder if my
hypothesis became uh that primates and
places that coexist non-human primates
that coexist with humans will prefer the
fruits uh that are under cultivation or
were brought by humans and therefore the
native fruits uh will be getting slowly
less common in places where there's
fruit under cultivation that human
cultivation effectively even if it
doesn't directly compete against native
fruits will indirectly compete by
basically
um by having the same sensory
experiences and preferences
as some of the fruit dispersions in the
forest
so fast forward to our first summer in
grad school and I decided that I was
going to test the hypothesis in um in a
new world forest in a rainforest in
Costa Rica and this is exactly the same
Forest where John vanderveer spread his
arms wide look at all the questions and
all I saw was green and and when it came
time to spend the several weeks doing
the research that we would then be
presenting for our our preliminary exams
in the fall I couldn't find any monkeys
no monkeys at all there were no monkeys
and I still in this day don't know why
there are no monkeys um but I was out in
that Forest every day all you know not
all day but like certainly every day
from dawn to to noon and then often
again in the late afternoon there's no
point in going out um in the hottest
part of the day usually uh unless you're
doing a particular kind of question but
um never found the monkeys but spent so
much time that I stumbled upon a natural
experiment that was happening in front
of me and it was with boys and frogs and
I'm not going to go into that whole
story now but I you know I pivoted
because I couldn't exactly test my
hypothesis on
um primates preferring fruits that
humans have brought in if I couldn't
find the damn monkeys could I
um but the story that the path that I
pivoted to is totally consistent with
the hypothesis that is still so far as I
know not tested but is still active as a
possibility in in that forest and that
actually kind of brings us to This
research that I want to say something
about but you had something you wanted
to well I want to say that we don't know
if the reason you couldn't find the
monkeys is because they were at the
market because they preferred human
fruit sorry they were buying up all the
mangoes yeah I don't think they were
buying them no no they were not they
were stuffing them in their in their
cheeks and other orifices
all right that got weird fast the
monkeys what do you expect all right
fair enough
um I mean they don't have suitcases do
they backpacks that's where my backpack
went yes yeah
um quite possible no okay sorry about
that
seed dispersal syndrome predicts ethanol
concentration of fruits in a tropical
dry forest
and to just translate that um right off
the bat tropical dry forest here is
Guanacaste it's uh it's a Costa Rican
dry Force it's not a uh rainforest like
we were just talking about it's a
seasonal dry forest but where there is
definite um seasonality of when things
are fruiting as there is anywhere but um
it's it's distinct there we spent a
little bit of time in Guanacaste
ourselves and what they mean here by sea
dispersal syndrome is they are
characterizing mammals and birds as the
two major groups of classes clades of
organisms that tend to be dispersing
fruits which to say plants have an
interest in having their seeds dispersed
and fruit is a lure and a gift to those
animals who would disperse that fruit
and of course some animals cheat and
they eat the fruit and they leave the
seed where it is or they don't do what
is uh what is expected but in general
whereas pollinators are often smaller
bodied organisms often insects
um some bats are pollinators some bats
are dispersers but um here we're talking
about
mostly larger bodied
um mammals and birds and
um and they I'll just I'll read this a
little bit from the introduction here
two prominent groups of vertebrate seed
dispersers birds and mammals differ in
their typical activity patterns and the
sensory systems they rely on to find and
consume fruit avian frugivores tend to
be highly visually oriented with
tetrachromatic color vision based on
four cone types and excellent visual
Acuity they also commonly swallow fruits
whole
fruits with bird dispersal syndromes are
correspondingly characterized by did I
say birds fruits with bird dispersal
syndromes are correspondingly
characterized by small size absence of a
protective husk and high visual contrast
alternatively forgivorous mammals
including primates bats rodents and
ungulates are typically dichromatic to
Cone Vision Red Green colorblind
although monochromacy single cone Vision
colorblindness is found in some
nocturnal species and trichromacy
three-convision human normal color
vision characterizes some primates
additionally mammalian frugivores often
have sensitive hands and mouths complex
dentition and larg olfactory bulbs in
olfactory receptor Gene repertoires
reflecting these anatomical features
mammalian frugivores rely Less on vision
and moral faction and manual buccal
haptic sensation and processing during
fruit foraging indeed fruits with mammal
dispersal syndromes are typically duller
and less visually conspicuous but more
odoriferous
they say odiferous I always say
odoriferous yeah I'm gonna go with
odorif for a second that's not what they
wrote and can be covered by thick husk
that requires manual or bugle processing
to remove okay so that's a cool setup
and that's so they're basically going to
go in
um and say
um in advance of looking at an advance
of measuring any fruit for ethanol
concentration we are going to describe
um the fruits in terms of what they just
said and say is this is this going to
have like mammal dispersal syndrome or
avian dispersal syndrome or is it some
combination they will say there's you
know there's a bit of it's not perfect
because as they allude to here primates
have actually moved away from the
typical mammal mode and we are no longer
um
lemurs less so but in the new world here
there are no lemurs it's all simeons
it's all um monkeys and us and um and
we've become once again more visual all
our olfactory lobe has become our
forebrain and and is the site of
processing of memory and and future
planning and we have frontation where
our eyes have moved to the front so we
have binocular vision and the size of
our noses have shrunk so we're more
bird-like in this way so you might
expect primate fruits to be to have a
have a have a like an intermediate
um kind of dispersal syndrome to bird
and mammal fruits because they might be
higher contrast and less odoriferous are
odiferous if you want
um so if I may have my screen back here
for a moment Zachary thank you surprised
you can hear me he's like way over there
um
I know he's listening to my mic he says
so
they then they characterize these um
fruits as such and then they went out
into the field and they uh they measured
the ethanol content in a bunch of them
and they indeed found basically what you
would ex what you would expect so
there's a there's some good
um
yeah that's that's too complicated I'm
not going to show the phylogeny but I
will show this
um which is a range of percentage of
ethanol concentration that's percent
alcohol by volume of ripe fruits of
species sampled in Guanacaste
um by sea dispersal syndrome the birds
are on the left the the bird distributed
fruits as far as they've assessed are on
the left the mammal distributed Foods as
far as they've assessed are on the right
and what we see with these uh these box
plots at the bottom
um is uh how much ethanol each of them
have and with the exception of a couple
of the what they think are bird
distributed fruits there's not much
ethanol at all whereas a bunch of the
mammal distributed fruits have a lot of
alcohol in them including including
that's not a word including your
favorite and mine spondius mambin oh
spondius is good and you know what and
so you can smell the alcohol when after
after it's dropped and you're just
walking across a field of spandias man
and that's really the only way you're
going to get funded because it's a
canopy tree yes the fruits are 75 feet
up but it is a very tasty tasty fruit
yeah but yeah it does uh quickly lean
over towards um you know it's getting a
little buzzed yeah I'm after five kind
of a fruit after five kind of a fruit
yeah so
um this is consistent with their
hypothesis
and um and there's a there's a lot that
we could say here but I really you know
really just wanted to uh point out
here's a path that is kind of related to
that path that I thought I saw
um those many years ago watching Crown
lemurs eat tamarind in Northern
Madagascar
um but a slightly different path that is
consistent with our understanding of
mammals frankly as luscious and birds
not so much and of uh mammals appearing
to prefer
um and it's you know there's there's no
way to know you know what was the first
thing but you've basically got a
positive feedback through selection uh
scenario here where if mammals
um going after fruit that tasted good to
them had a slight preference for alcohol
in their fruit than those fruits that
had a little bit of alcohol in them got
got their seeds dispersed more and on
and on and on and on so
did they have a pre-existing hypothesis
about which fruits were going to have
more ethanol and a rationale
uh it would just just that they thought
that the mammal the mammal distributed
fruits would have more ethanol because
they're they're treating the ethanol as
a reward distinct yeah yes exactly and
there's a number of reasons for that and
this gets into there's there's a lot of
chemistry here and it's still very
unclear uh I think I think we just we
science doesn't really know fully what's
going on here but
um
you get twice as many calories from the
sugar and alcohol as you do the sugar
and sugar
uh and uh while there is clearly a
toxicity associated with high alcohol
there may be a benefit at low alcohol
levels so you might indeed find that
this is not a binary like alcohol good
or alcohol bad but a little bit of
alcohol like no alcohol not as
preferable for the for the mammals who
are Distributing fruits a little bit of
alcohol good a lot of alcohol not so
good I think I may have gone I wondered
also about the
protecting
the reward if you're going to put a seed
if you're going to wrap a reward around
a seed
and that reward goes bad so that the
disperser won't eat it because they
might become sick or yes it doesn't
taste good is how they would perceive it
right that alcohol
might prevent the growth of certain
things that would tend to take over a
fruit and therefore become something
that uh if a mammal can process it
they would be willing you know and like
I say I've eaten plenty of spontious
fruits that were a little past their
Prime and they do have that alcoholic
kind of sense about them yes and it's
not
terribly off-putting it's not as good as
a perfectly exactly ripe spongius yeah
but it's not bad yeah no and I actually
I found myself
um foraging for blackberries yesterday I
went on a walk
uh since I wasn't allowed to go into
human company so um I went on a on a
beautiful walk and
um certainly tried a couple of
blackberries that weren't there yet and
had a couple that were perfect and a
couple that felt a little bit past their
Prime and just a little little a little
fermented
um use just a couple
um more intriguing which is interesting
that's Bird fruit
um
blackberries yeah
yeah I mean for one thing the growth
habit of the plant makes it very
difficult for anything that can't fly to
get them do you eat them yeah around the
edges yeah no deer at them all the time
that's true
yeah I mean and then the blackberries
that are here introduced they're MLA and
mostly so you know it's all there's all
sorts of layers of like what what was
the intention here but
um I'm not I I would put Blackberry at
uh at an intermediate uh you know it
doesn't have the husk it's not yeah
giant it does have tiny seeds
um so
um so it does it does fit the avian
model to some degree but um they also do
have a a delightful smell
when the sun is here that's true I
accept that this is a generalist
actually
people don't talk enough about
generalist
syndromes yeah usually syndromes isolate
you to a clade of dispersers or uh
Distributors well and I think I mean uh
with the Blackberry with any of those
that that clade of berries uh where it's
um
is it true no I can't remember what the
what the category is but
um lots of tiny little seeds that are
inherently unextractable from the fruit
um you swallow that you swallow you are
going to be taking this like they don't
like these fruits are not interested in
toilets they have that's a that's a loss
for them yeah um but for everything else
that's eating them as as long as they
don't have a digestive tract that's you
know a centimeter long and it doesn't
come out right away they're going to be
dispersing the fruit somewhat so unless
there's something that the Blackberry is
benefiting from in the gut of birds or
the gut of mammals that is um you know
scratching it up and making it more
likely to
um to to germinate um I think they're
they're pretty generalist here's a
couple of other little little
um
fun things from this paper uh which just
went tiny on me
no no this is from the discussion
notably the metabolic pathway used to
use to ferment sugars and produce
ethanol emerged in the early Cretaceous
at approximately the same time that
angiosperms shifted from producing small
wind dispersed fruits to large fleshy
vertebrate dispersed fruits with
fermentable sugars
so that's cool the timing is Con is
convergent
and then some forgivers mammals
including African elephants squirrel
monkeys pigtail macaques and I eyes are
sensitive to ethanol odors as they can
smell them interesting eye eyes is on
that list and it shows up on this final
list some mammals including humans
African gray apes and I eyes exhibit a
mutation in their adh7 Gene that yields
a 40-fold Improvement in enzymatic
efficiency for ethanol metabolism and
these animals may have significant
exposure to dietary ethanol humans
African great apes and eye eyes what are
eye eyes doing on the list IIs are this
crazy clade of lemurs that again are
only on Madagascar and insectivorous and
and well insectivorous but they also
they're eating gums they're like they're
they're using that long finger of theirs
to dig out stuff and and
um
so what what is happening there but it
does seem that we have a particular
ability to deal with alcohol and
therefore uh and and add to that
although they don't say it here I
suspect that we humans are also
sensitive to ethanol odors that we can
we can process it better
um enzymatic enzymatic efficiency for
ethanol metabolism and we can sense it
better and once you have those two
things uh you're probably going to seek
it out some if it has some value again
at low doses but not at High
yeah that's really cool yeah
okay that's my um
that's that's my path through
tropical forests for today all right
yeah cool
[Music]